that's what they need the most because
everybody in their life is judging them
and telling them what they should do and
they feel like a piece of garbage
that's what they're telling themselves
you don't have to be the expert on all
those things yet you can just talk about
what you're doing and what you've seen
with those things but the more you have
the conversations and the more you start
helping people the discussions
can become
coaching or mentoring how do people know
it all i exist
yay is part of our movement makers
program is part of that we're doing a ig
live together so
what do you got first uh thank you very
much for uh having like the honor to
join the group it's amazing also the
book
love it
i wanted to ask a few questions on uh
opening a new youtube channel
which i'm planning to do
let's go yeah
let's go taking over it for a long time
already but uh and then also i have a
question asked event i know we're short
in time but i really appreciate it so
basically when i open i'm not really a
technology guy now when i open a new
channel
how do i get my native uh language is
not english but i want to do it in
english
how do i get people
uh to my channel if i'm not like really
a social media guy and i'm not in those
worlds my goal is to
light people's path and give them a
feeling of empowerment and belonging and
what is the business model ultimately
like you want to sell coaching or what
what do you right now i'm not selling
coaching in the future maybe i'll do
that but now my goal is 100 just helping
people by i believe i'll stay in two
seconds if you invest it's going to be
called invest and smile
so if you invest in six areas of life
uh your life your path will light and uh
you'll smile
i like it dude okay so
and then but where does that go is that
a course is that a book is that a speech
like where is it right now only to help
people like their path
uh
in the future maybe i'll take it for
coaching but i'm not
i'm not looking to yeah
okay is coaching interesting for you i
don't know in the long run i love
coaching uh also now people sometimes
come for me like if you're asking my
vision i could also see like having
seminars weekends and like
that's doing in the long run maybe also
a book but i'm saying step by step right
now i'm thinking about it too much for a
long time because i'm thinking maybe i'm
not credible enough or things like that
so first i just want to start
sure okay so uh but i would start down
two parallel paths the first is
you have your six six steps to having
happiness right
so your videos are all about
one of those six steps
so each time you make a video it's got
to touch one of those six steps and in
terms of making content it could be from
your own story your own background your
like how you got there like history
stuff like way back of who you are and
where you came from we're telling
stories from our past
um it could be stories from your present
you know how did you pick that plant
behind you and and why is there like a
yellow
you know rainbow on your wall and like
i'm assuming they're there for some
reason in intention
your thoughts coming into doing this
instagram live together uh how does it
touch on one of the six points
in your happiness chart
and so we're
only six points right i mean i say the
same stuff over and over again yeah it's
kind of six points but if you just let
me i'll explain it so basically i
believe that if the mind is in the
middle but if you invest in the mind
relationships uh movement activity uh
sleep nutrition and relationships so
that will light your path so every time
it's going to be a different when i'm
not going to do all of them and i don't
want it to do only for my stories
because i also listen to like i learn
from you i learn like i'm only one
person i also want to bring from other
places but how how how do i get to
people like no one knows
like i don't want to put out tons of
money in marketing before i started
doing anything
so in the content i agree you don't want
to have a video that talks about all six
things unless you just you can have a
video that explains the
the you know the six things in general
like here's my philosophy but then the
future videos are diving more specific
on each one but basically everything
you're gonna make
i have the same
10 to 20 themes that i talk about on
repeat
but i have different stories that i'll
use depending on what's going on so you
have your six themes
and you can have different stories that
you talk about depending what's going on
it doesn't only have to be about you i'm
just saying you is important because
it's your it's your framework right so
in terms of kinds of stories to tell
it's from the past foundation stories
but also new stuff that's coming up
right now something's gonna happen this
week that can fit into one of your six
things that you can make a video on
um
then we can also make content about
other people and something in the news
that you see and that you like or don't
like or somebody you know an experience
you had in movie makers or with a fellow
movement maker a live stream that you
did with somebody else right that
becomes a story this is like how do you
take what's going on in the world not
just your world but the world
and make it make sense in terms of one
of the six areas of
of content
the reason why i suggested coaching if
you liked it is
you don't have to get paid at the
beginning like you're worried about your
experience and credibility you don't
know what the answer is going to be he
doesn't have to be coaching yet it could
just be conversations
you basically walk people through
the sex steps and wherever they're
struggling the most you have you have
the conversation around it
which then eventually leads to more
expertise which leads to more
you know could actually then become
coaching could then become something
paid could then become a book or a
seminar or something else but
when you're creating content in a vacuum
meaning if it's just you
talking to the camera you don't know how
well your thoughts are being received or
how to adjust them
but when you're talking to somebody look
here example look okay our kanyo just
wrote six areas
are the six areas again here
yeah mine mind movement
relationships
nutrition sleep
and i'm missing right now one of them
my movement relationship is sleep
i just got a blackout but okay
okay well listen so that if that's at
the core then the next
financial behavior financial behavior
yeah
so that needs to be printed somewhere so
that you know you remember it and you
can refer back to it uh and you can also
give it to other people and and what
happened right there when when they
asked the question
what are the six areas
you don't have to be i mean you should
know what they are is fine but but like
you don't have to be the expert on all
those things yet you can just talk about
what you're doing and what you've seen
with those things
but the more you have the conversations
and the more you start helping people
the discussions
can become
coaching or mentoring
at the beginning it's not right at the
beginning it's just going to be
a conversation but in having those
conversations like if if he says
so we said those six areas
maybe somebody like somebody's even mind
movement relationships sleep financial
and blocking out no that was uh what was
my
movement relationships
movement sleep nutrition relationships
and
financial behavior nutrition yes i'm
used to saying in my own language in
english it's uh
it's different
that's great yeah i mean and that's
awesome and so now he's saying thank you
right maybe he has a follow-up question
maybe he says well what do you what do
you mean by mind
and then you explain what you mean by
mind
and then maybe that leads to another
question and you don't have to have all
the answers yet because it's not a it's
not a paid coaching session
but it's a discussion that as people ask
questions it makes your model better
it makes the framework better
so i would be trying to do
videos with people talking about
different elements of those of that
framework right an easy one is already
within mover makers to do the challenge
that we do every month
i'm learning how to use discord uh me
and technology are still learning how to
work with each other i didn't have
instagram until the second i just
downloaded because i knew i needed for
now
there you go well and you made it happen
so it's great but i mean that
somewhere inside of mind you know
there's there's the answer every month
in movie makers you there's a challenge
that we do
and as a theme and part of that theme is
then doing your own video on that topic
but then also three collaboration videos
with other people makers
so if the theme is going to be you know
confidence or consistency or resilience
or whatever right um
you know if you take confidence as the
theme
then
how does confidence fit into
one of those six things and you have a
conversation about it
and every time you talk about it
the the model becomes clearer uh yeah
for sure no i understand that and i i
really appreciate the fact you know that
there's a community uh i think that's
amazing i didn't think about that
uh
and what i want to do in the future is
also have interviews because i do i i
chose those six steps through things
that went in life but
there are people that are experts uh so
let's say i was in real estate i didn't
know how to take the hammer and build
the wall or do drywall but like knowing
to bring the people to talk about this
stuff so i think what you said the
combination between
right the beginning talking to other
people and then also bringing every time
maybe an expert later on but my first
question is how how do people know it
all i exist like you're saying
in the beginning don't care about that
like just talk to people in the
community and like how do i reach out to
people
almost by the nature like if people
don't know who you are and you're
reaching out and then you get something
then you get people to follow right
yeah sure by making content if it's good
content and people want more of that
good content so i mean movie makers is
your easiest start
that
they will go live with you
they'll get like just like that we're
going live right now you set up your
account people are now learning about
you if they like the the six steps or
they like you or they want to learn more
about your journey they can now follow
your account and find out more about you
right at the beginning i wouldn't i
wouldn't um like the biggest thing is
just momentum
it's just creating
and the more you can create with other
people the better because it allows you
to refine your thinking a little bit
more
so i would do a mix of collaborations
and and
the challenge is only three people right
coach queen kelly says i'll go live with
you you say that there you go
go go
remember coach queen kelly and and send
her a message i learned
right like but that's it but you can
learn that i mean nobody knows any of
the platforms at the beginning
you figure it out as you go you didn't
know anything about nutrition either and
you didn't know anything about finance
either you didn't know anything about
the mind either and how did you learned
it right uh yeah
so same thing
instagram is
is you already figured it out look you
started you just created your account
today when we went live like the camera
was facing backwards you know
and now we're here
you're already better than me amazing
yesterday right that's how learning's
that's how the learning goes
um
in our challenge in movie makers which
the requirement is to do three people
but i would
a lot more more sure
so
when i do a video i could put it also on
my youtube channel and also on instagram
or you don't recommend to do it on both
i would do both for now
honestly like because it's just momentum
you don't you just set up your instagram
account you you don't have a youtube
channel
it's just about getting stuff up
to to
know what it's like to get stuff up like
just to build the
it's like you're asking for the perfect
workout plan
and you haven't done a push-up
you're just sitting on the couch right
and so it's
in terms of movement what's the perfect
movement plan
how about you start with a walk outside
right like if movement's one of your
things and somebody's been sitting on
the couch their entire life and they
want a movement plan
you're asking like what's the perfect
movement just go for a walk in the sun
outside man like that's what we need and
then we'll figure out it's not just the
strategy it's like what do you like
doing
so as you start talking to people and
doing collaborations or doing interviews
if you interview you message people say
hey i'd love to interview you talking
about real estate or talking about
nutrition or talking about movement or
talking about whatever
you just message them like instagram has
just people from the community you just
message them and not
whoever you want some people in the
community some people random like
the more you can make it personal just
like imagine you're sending an email to
somebody
do you only send email to people who you
already know no you can reach out to
other people too you can even
you can even email
the use email instead of instagram as
the outreach and say i want to do an
interview with you
and people might ignore you and people
won't see it and some people will see it
and say yeah let's do something you're
saying to do a combination of me talking
sometimes and some videos also combined
with other people
like sometimes it will be only me and
sometimes
other people and if i understand
correctly
you you're saying that the first video
please correct me if i'm wrong the first
video should be like introduction of
what's the goal of this
channel
doesn't have to be just make a first
video like the first video should be
hey guys
i've been sitting on making videos for a
long time and uh
i'm working on a relationship with
technology but i know i want to serve so
i don't know what i'm doing yeah
here we go
post right like and go like
there's no doesn't like release perfect
it doesn't matter what you do in your
first video alipaz says you can
interview me if you want i'm a movement
student with yoga yeah
look
ali paz they reach out to ali paz
a-l-y-p-a-w-s
there you go you got another one right
it's like
you start and here's the thing as you do
more the reason why i suggest talking to
people is because
it it starts to crystallize the thinking
and
it allows you to make better decision
decisions going forward like when you
say movement there's so many just look
at movement as an example there's so
many things you could do
right
do salsa dance do you go trampolining do
you go skiing do you go to to a gym do
you join a running club like and there's
no right answer does the right answer
for you
but there's no like one right answer for
everybody
and how do you find it like
don't worry about getting to become a
professional salsa dancer yet
get off the couch and go for a walk
right and like we start to build the
practice in
and so in talking to people what you'll
find is
maybe you want to do more of those kinds
of people and those topics maybe you
talk to ally paws and talk about yoga
and now you like fall in love with yoga
and you want to do a lot more with yoga
and and you create a weekly series
talking yoga doing yoga and it becomes
like a big thing for you or or that was
one and done and like you don't want to
do any more yoga like by doing it
you start to learn if you liked it
and by doing the stuff that you like
then we can work worry about the right
strategy yeah afterwards i understand
that and i do appreciate that you know
what's funny evan when people come to me
it's really like it's easy for me to
tell them this and i think you should do
abcd
but then
when it comes to me i'm like yeah you
know what
uh so that's that's kind of funny like i
realized that a few times uh i want to
ask you a question about uh
two last questions because i know every
other time one is
is any way like i know you always offer
hope to other people like i would love
to know what's what's the way uh
we i'll say i can help you as a person
that's number one and uh number two
uh you talk about the book always a bad
belief and believe is uh three different
types of belief
but my question is evan how do you hope
someone believes in himself when he's in
rock bottom because you know when
someone's running outside and having fun
or dancing salsa with you know
movement so that's fun but when
someone's all the way down like how do
you how do you hope and believe in
himself usually people in that place
won't want even to listen like i hope i
was clear
yeah so
um
you're not going to get somebody
uh to go off and then join a salsa class
like that they're really down um
it's honestly be there with them like if
they're really
i think you have to be if you're at a
ground level then you're ready to grow
but if you're underground then your time
you just have to get back to ground
level this is how i think about it so
there's there's the achievers who need
to push and it's like they need the
honest feedback to say let's go like
build this and yes it's belief and
positivity but more like pushed you got
to go where
somebody who is
below ground right now
they don't they don't need advice
because the advice is only coming off as
judgment
if you tell somebody who's at rock
bottom that they should go and pick up a
salsa class to get moving
it's love from you but it's being
interpreted as a judgment judgment from
the person tell me what i need to do
they feel it as it's internalized as
judgment even though it's love coming
from you your advice is judgment
it feels as judgment even though it's
not like you're giving love but it comes
across to them as judgment because they
can't hear anything
if somebody's already at ground level
ready to grow it's like hey man how do i
grow like i really need to boost my
movement and you're going to say go do
this
they can they're ready for the message
but somebody who's on the ground just
needs to get back to ground level and so
it's sitting with them and listening to
them and just being with them and
letting them feel heard
and don't give them any advice
because you might be the first person to
even
ever listen to them
and they might tell you things that
they've never told their spouse or their
parents or their other family members
it's just creating a space for them to
they need to you need to unburden
yourself from all of the all of the
weight that's on you before you can
start to run
and so i wouldn't even worry about what
to say to them don't don't use your
mouth use your ears listen to them
give them a space to be heard
and then you're waiting for them to ask
for help like giving somebody home
because that doesn't open anyway
it's just it's judgment it just they'll
feel worse because they feel like now
you're another person is judging them
so if they're actually at rock bottom
you're just sitting there and listening
to them and being with them
and helping them doesn't someone in rock
bottom want you not of course not always
the sunrise like to throw the rope that
he'll need help or throwing the rope is
basically listening and having empathy
or not empathy i'm not sure i'm asking
yeah i mean like throwing the rope isn't
isn't the advice you're going to give to
again is just sitting with them
okay
just listening just being allowing them
to be heard
that's that's what they need the most
because nobody everybody in their life
is judging them and telling them what
they should do and they feel like a
piece of garbage
that's what they're telling themselves
and and that person you can't go and and
start dancing with and doing a run with
so it's just it's just being there and
if you're the only person who is around
them who is not judging them and not
telling them what they need to do
and actually just hearing them then what
ends up happening is
they say hey what what do you think i
should do
and then you tell them
but
you you're you're opening windows you
have to wait for them to go to the
window right or open the door they have
to go to the door before you can
actually help them and and that's like
here's the problem it feels like it's
not enough
for the achievers when you can see them
you see this huge potential in somebody
and you want to help them build and grow
it feels like it's not enough that
listening alone is not enough
but it's it's it's a tremendous step
it's the exact thing that they need and
it's more than enough and if you can
just focus on like you're judging the
size of the step
you want them to take a giant leap for
them just like an inch forward is a
giant leap
we're judging the size of the staff
and so that first step is just listen
listening is amazing
and then in terms of i know i know we're
kind of up on time but you're asking how
can you support me and to believe in i i
um
you know i appreciate the spirit of that
message um
when a coach gives you advice
the best thing you can do for the coach
is to follow the advice
so
that's the highest form of like if
you're going to help somebody with their
movement and then they go off and they
actually start moving and they write
back to you in three months and say dude
like i did it and look at me now that's
the best form
of
thank you or gratitude more than
buying your book or
whatever else right so
more than
buying anything i'm making
the best way to say thank you or help me
is to do it like start your youtube
channel
contact allypaws and do the yoga gotta
interview together
get things like like that's the and you
know from the other side right when
people say hey you helped me and you did
they did the advice that's that's why we
do what we do
it's the greatest feeling of all time
that's the best way to pay back a mentor
more than
buying their book or course or whatever
else okay consider this as done
perfect i appreciate it i love it
and and you're already yeah i mean
you're already doing it you did it here
right you said yes to this
it's like i've never done instagram live
before i don't even have an instagram
account
your picture is like a beach or
something i don't know what's on there
was amazing
but it's great
and you did it and you're here and you
took the next you took the first step
right and that's the most for movement
that's the most important thing is
the first step
now let's use that you know once you're
in motion it's easier to stay in motion
so coach queen kelly and allie pods and
everybody else like reach out and and
started going and that's like the
greatest thing is for you and three
months to say look here's everybody that
i interviewed and look at my channel
and look at where it began
that's amazing thank you very much i
appreciate it thanks
hey
and there she is
it's so nice to see your face how are
you doing
i'm great how are you i'm great i've met
reina is the first time we're actually
connecting kind of i guess we're not in
person but close enough we have the same
publisher that we share cara paulsen and
uh i saw you on her stories and i just
love the energy and the vibe and
um there's just a little voice that said
you know what you should reach out and
do an ig live together i'm gonna ask her
and you said yes and so here we are
we're making it happen
well the answer to how is yes
so
i just said yes and i i didn't even know
really what i was saying yes to but it's
just so great to
to talk to you in person as i've
listened to your books on my audible and
watched you with kyra and you wrote a
book in less than a week
just huge huge props to you and all that
you're doing and the difference that you
make for so many people
i love it so as i was watching your
stories just before we went live and you
said you did something difficult this
morning that that prepped you for this
what was that difficult thing
uh a cold plunge
okay have you done a cold plunge before
i've done a cold plunge yet
so my husband loves the cold plunge and
he's created a sanctuary on the side of
our house that has an outdoor shower and
a sauna and a cold plunge
and every morning i go out there and i
say the hard things that i'm about to do
in my life and my projects my books
coaching all of those things
and then i'm like okay if i can get in
this then i can do all of those hard
things because it's really hard to take
the step into the freezer is that a
daily thing that you do i'm trying to
make it a daily thing as often as
possible yeah i love that that was a
setup for this and teaching yourself you
do hard things you know first thing in
the morning we didn't really have an
agenda for this it's just more like i
reach out and i thought we could do an
id live together what where does your
heart take you would you rather talk
about your book and what you're doing in
healing through relationships or is
there something that i can help you with
where you are in your journey that would
be of value for you either way where is
your heart taking you
oh wow that is like a hard split
decision
uh can we do a little of both
okay cool um okay well let's start with
how it can help what i mean where are
you at what's
if you had to ask a question or two what
um what feedback could i could i give
um i feel like
i'm at this tipping point where like i
have a few coaching clients i'm in in
the middle of
publishing these three books
one uh with my husband that i have been
writing for like eight years
about our marriage divorce and
remarriage to each other
and
um and then as i was writing that book
this collaboration book with kira came
up
where
that's like creating some momentum
and then i have a children's book that's
kind of about my inner child and and my
uh upbringing so
i feel like i'm at this tipping point
where i'm
gaining momentum on instagram i'm
sharing my stories
but i also feel a little bit
like i don't know what else to do
i don't know where else to go
in order to do what what's the goal
um
to help as many people as i can like my
message is
forgiveness it's hoping through
relationships
and it's building resiliency even though
you've had really hard things
and ultimately is it
your business model is going to be the
book or programs or coaches or
consulting or what what's the what's the
business ultimately going to be
good question
um
it's going to be coaching
and i have a couple of digital courses
already and then these books
and you know ultimately
i really love i'm a born performer i've
been singing my entire life i love being
on a stage
um i would love to speak
so that that is my personal goal i just
want to like be out there and be with
people and be on a stage maybe speak and
sing that would be really great
speaking sing okay cool so listen
whatever you want to make money doing
the best content to make is show me the
process of you doing it
so
take all of those things that you love
and now think how can i show people how
i do this so if singing is going to be a
big part of what you want to do than
having regular singing content like
random singing content if coaching's
what you want to do and sell then show
me you coaching
like okay like live sessions with people
like this yeah this is like this if i
wanted to sell coaching this would be a
great example you know it's like i'm
this is it i mean i didn't even didn't
know what we were gonna do when we went
live just like hey just show up and
we'll see what happens but this is a
great example of coaching uh and so it's
about your book is about relationships
right healing through a broken
relationship yeah so you have people
come on who
are dealing with their relationship that
they feel is broken and they need some
feedback and guidance and help and care
and love and your
you know why i
i fell in love with your vibe and i mean
like again i didn't know you we've never
met you before before this
but
your your
just the way you sink into your heart in
the care and the energy is just really
calming and peaceful and loving and
i could see you
i could see you if you're doing coaching
sessions where people would open
themselves up to you where they haven't
told anybody else the things that they
might tell you
okay i don't know if you've already
experienced that with friends or family
or other people you know in your life
but where you just create a safe space
for people to share things that they are
afraid to admit to anybody else
yeah which makes you a great coach
because it's like great listening but
then also being able to give great
advice
and so some people uh will not want to
be public
you know some people may not want to be
coached on an instagram
video right like a youtube video and
that's cool you don't need everybody to
say yes
um but
the fact that you're an author
doesn't mean you're going to be a great
coach
true
but you are but like people don't know
that right like if the fact that you
wrote a book doesn't mean that people
will think i want to hire her as my
coach
so the best way to get coaching clients
is to show me you coaching the best way
to get book sales is to show me you with
the book and teaching lessons from the
book um the best way to get more
speaking gigs is to show me you speaking
so you start booking speaking gigs
you know even for free like go speak at
your local ymca or
library or high school or tedx talk like
it doesn't have to be some giant
you know mel robbins on stage in front
of an arena full of people
just the fact that you are speaking
makes me think oh she's a speaker i
might hire her to come and speak at my
next event
and so it's like the more you can have
fun in doing the content and the more
that it actually
in showing the process leads to
a business result that then like the
ultimate goal is impact right it's like
how do i reach more people and if you
turn it into a business and you can
reach more people right if it's like you
part-time on the side doing it then
we don't want it to take another eight
years to like get the next thing out
right right but if you're making money
doing it then you can have a team then
you can invest more in people then you
can reach a lot more people with your
message and your content yeah that makes
so much sense it seems like as you say
it it's so logical okay
yes i've done that why does that not
make sense and why does that not come to
my mind and can i just say the reason it
doesn't come into my mind to begin with
is because i get stuck on the trajectory
of where i'm going and it feels so far
away like
i don't know how i'm gonna get there and
then i get stopped
so
stop steps like you're talking about
yeah yeah so like how many people how
many people follow you on instagram
right now i think i'm about 1400.
perfect the first 1400's the heart is
1400 so you're already on your way you
got you got the momentum um to my new
book coming out uh the way to do it is
to message the people who are following
you and say you're going to start a new
show
once a day or once a week or whatever
you know feels right for you
of coaching
and
do they want to be
your guest where you're going to coach
them for free where normally they would
have to hire you to do coaching
but here it's free coaching but it's
going to be public and hopefully in that
person's story other people can learn
from them as well
and some people will say no i don't want
it to be
public they might ask you can i hire you
though to be my coach you know now
now we have a coaching like how are you
actually coaching people now and getting
paid to do it yeah perfect so it's a
good lead-in right that you can offer
them the free one on your instagram
but if they they say no they might want
to just hire you to be their coach
anyway
yeah and then you'll get some people who
say yes and then that's how you start
your show
and the beautiful thing with that is you
just have to show up
you don't need to prepare like if you
think about making an instagram video or
a youtube video there's a lot of work to
prepare in script and like what am i
gonna you know we're coaching you just
show up you say hey
susan
welcome how can i help what's on your
mind what's in your heart
and
shares and then you go help her um and
it's actually fun because you feel like
what you're doing
matters and helps and is having an
impact and maybe susan ends up
you know wanting to work with you and
hire you to be her coach cool but if not
then all the people watching
as you continue to build up the momentum
behind it well some of them will say hey
that's really cool i love how i love
what she did i love i love this random
person never heard of her before but i'm
maybe she's the coach for me
i love that thank you
and it's just the most fun you know it's
like you feel like it matters
because 1400 people is a lot of people
but
it's hard to it doesn't feel tangible
right
like that's a small town you got 14 you
had an entire town of people who are
following you
but it's hard to feel tangible but when
you see one person and you see her eyes
like oh my gosh that you're so right
randa and your little tweak then sets
them on a different path because you
gave them give her the answer
it makes you feel like what you're doing
really matters
right well and that's like that's the
point is to be able to witness and
listen to someone
and acknowledge where they're at and
validate where they're at
and then be able to assist them in tools
that i've learned and tools that i'm
certified in like that's that's the
whole point
yeah so
you already have enough people who are
following you
you just video message them
one by one and say hey i'm starting a
new show this is what i did at the
beginning when i started my show i was
on an airplane from la to toronto and i
messaged people one by one to say do you
want to be
my my guest i'm going to start a new
show i went live every day i did it in
toronto so they had to be in we did it
on instagram live but they were sitting
next to me oh cool i had a smaller pool
of people to pull from because it had to
be local where doing this could be
anywhere in the world
and i booked the first five people
to do my show for the first week
and built momentum
it's scary
but worth it and if it feels right then
the best thing you can do is go
like for momentum you know immediate
action like right after this go book
your first person
or tomorrow and launch a show
um i'll tell you because when i had the
idea on the airplane from my way to
toronto and i was 100 like this is going
to be so much fun i can't wait to do
this and then
come day the day that was a friday night
i was flying back to toronto and i was
going to start my show on monday
on monday morning i show up and like i
don't want to do the show zero zero
percent
i'm too busy i don't have time for this
what if i don't know how to answer their
question what if i can't help all of
like the insecurities and doubts
right 100 on friday night turned to zero
percent on monday morning
and it was only because i had booked
the first people that i had to i'm not
going to not show up like somebody was
in my studio i had to go there and meet
them right so more likely to actually
follow through
so
yeah if like it feels right then it's
booking your first people
and asking if they want to do the show
i feel like you're reading my mind
because i'll i'm asking questions in my
mind and then you're automatically
answering them
well that then you know it's the right
path yeah and so it's really as easy as
after right after this you spend an hour
sending messages to people on instagram
and i like a quick video message
and just
10 seconds you know hey susan thanks for
following me i'm starting a new show
coaching women through their
relationships or is it just women are
you coach guys too no men too cool
you know but obviously you you know if
it's susan you're saying women if it's
bill you're seeing anyways but you know
hey bill i'm certain thank you so much
for following me and starting a new show
uh helping people through their
relationships if you have any issues and
you'd like me to coach you one-on-one
i'm certain to show next next week if
you want to be my first guest let me
know
and then again hey susan i like i even
do it walking i like getting fresh air
and like walking and get a vibe so i'm
walking down the street while i'm doing
it but um
yeah just like 10
second videos at a time to the people
who follow you and at worst it's a it's
a touch point to thank them for
following you
right
and nobody sends personal messages like
that
yeah yeah i love that
i like being in people's space like that
with a video it's so much more
personable
than a text
yeah
and and fun and and they'll see it and
and even if some people will say yes
like if you send five messages you may
not get somebody to say yes right so we
gotta we gotta
send more you know like let's put 50 on
our list of 1400 let's send 50 messages
you'll get some people
but even for the ones who don't say yes
you're you're building a relationship
somebody might write back and say how
much they love your content or looking
forward to your book or all of these
things that are built it's crazy how
much a 10-second video message impacts
somebody
because nobody's reaching out to their
followers and just thanking them
yeah so it's something i do every
morning i go for i call it a believe
walk i go through my believe walk and uh
and i'll just
i'll just randomly pick people who
follow me and send personal messages
and just i love that
that's awesome yeah and it feels good
it's like it's not just a good strategy
it's a good strategy but it also feels
good that it's like these are 1400 real
people you know maybe some of them are
bots you know maybe there's 100 bots so
it's like 1 300 like but they're real
people those are real people who've got
goals and dreams and aspirations and
relationship problems and all of these
things and they're following you because
you posted something that touched their
heart in some way
and so just being able to say thank you
and reach out
will lead to all sorts of
crazy good things but especially booking
you know people for your show
thank you
thank you
like that's an easy one that's a
no-brainer and then you can clip the
content and do like you know take
highlight moments and reuse them or take
one-liners and put them up on your
channel um
speaking should be you speaking
yeah like you're
ideally it's with some
at least it looks like it's in front of
some kind of crowd
in high schools or universities or
again ymcas like i got started at the
ymca and three people came to my first
event
but it doesn't matter like you go and
you serve you help those three people
you know action is action yeah
um and then the other one's what the
book or the courses
um
yeah yeah digital courses
so another great thing to do is you have
somebody um
like is the course already ready to sell
or you're working on it yeah yeah
and are like you already made some sales
on it or you're working on it i have
made one sale perfect this is great the
first sale is the hardest sale you know
as long as it's not to your husband than
your mom or something
but no that's like that's the great
start and what you can do is um
for the for the early people who buy the
course
offer the do an instagram live with them
too
okay
do you know you know actually let's not
say her name but like you know let's
let's say her name was jill right who
bought your first course cool you reach
out to jill and say hey jill thank you
so much for buying my course i hope it's
being valuable for you um
do you want to do a bonus instagram live
with me where whatever questions you've
got whatever you want to talk about i'm
here to serve and hopefully your
questions can also serve the audience
watching too
um
again maybe jill is super introverted or
shy and doesn't want to come on camera
but like at the very worst case you're
building you're saying thank you and
she's going to feel recognized which is
always great but if she says yes then
she's going to come on your instagram
live you're going to go and get content
together and then what's she gonna say
she's gonna say oh i just bought your
course it's amazing thank you so much
now you're talking about the course
without talking about the course
yeah so now anybody watching can learn
about oh she's got a course what's the
course all about
right so anybody knew was getting into
the course you can offer it doesn't
scale incredibly well right like you
can't do it for everybody if you're
going to sell we're going to sell a
million of these courses right so
so rand is not going to do a million ig
lives but for the first people come in
and it could still be part of you know
if you had like once a week coaching
from your followers and then once a week
coaching from people who bought the
course
as you start to make more sales
even once a week coaching people who
bought the book do you have any books
for sale yet or not yet they're all in
yeah cool yeah they they're all slated
for uh september
okay well we're not that far away like
you can even do pre-orders right you
already have the book title do you have
a cover you're working on the cover
i have a cover yeah cool so you have a
title you have a cover
um you can do pre-orders that if
somebody buys 10 copies of the book they
also get an instagram live with you
or 100 copies or a thousand copies or
whatever um and then we start we start
talking about the book right even though
the book's not ready yet until september
she bought
she bought 10 copies and she's so she
gets the ig live with you and then she's
going to come on and say i'm so excited
for your book it comes out in september
right i can't wait to get a copy so now
we're talking about the book without
talking about the book and still serving
her to help her or him with you know
whatever issues they've got going on so
it's just fun like it helps promote the
thing that you're trying to promote and
it doesn't mean stop doing i'm not i'm
not super deep on your content and like
what you've been posting and frequency
but um
are you how like what's your cadence how
often are you actually posting content
right now
um
i'm probably
two or three times a week
okay
and does that feel good does that feel a
lot does that feel
it feels like not enough one of those i
have a podcast so one is a podcast every
week um i'm trying to ramp that up and
do reels and
and add more content that way
um so i feel like i feel like three to
four would be
a manageable number for me
a good number and what do you talk about
on the podcast or what's the format um
gosh i have my husband on there um
it's like whatever spiritual message
downloads to my brain
it's it's not pigeon holed to one thing
i love it that's great
so you have the podcast and then it
really just depends on the on the
cadence and how much
you want to put in and how much it
builds you versus drains you um
this is an example
this
builds me
like
today's my mentoring day all i'm doing
is mentoring the people on my team
we've got 40 people on the team and it's
just all day like 25 minutes on five
minute break 25 minutes on five minute
break like into the next person next
yeah but then like two o'clock eastern i
break to do this because it it doesn't
drink i'm gonna leave this with more
energy than i came in mm-hmm you're
giving me energy you're not taking that
energy
and that's most of the time like this i
guess is sometimes you have somebody
that's not as great but for the most
part like i leave more connected to the
mission than why i do what i do
than less
um and it's because of having somebody
on with you who
who you feel like you helped like if you
feel like you served today and not just
at home
with the computer it makes a big
difference
so
the cadence is up to you
obviously but if you had a regular
series around coaching people who are
following you you know regular series
around
people who bought the book or
pre-ordered the book a regular series
around people who bought the course
that could be you know three four or
five
instagram lives a week
it could even just be a regular show
that you go live with and start taking
questions from people that's what i do
like it's just
two o'clock eastern or going live either
instagram or in one of my other
communities two o'clock eastern we go
live and i just set that in my schedule
for half an hour and it's like right in
the middle of the day
and it really works for me for my flow
and then it doesn't feel like work or i
have to make content or i'm struggling
with like what do i come up with next
right as you're helping somebody you're
going to say something genius hopefully
in some in in this i said something
genius but then we can cut and turn into
a reel or turn into something else right
yeah uh hopefully you know hopefully
when you're helping somebody you say
you're going to say a lot more genius
things that then turns into maybe 10
reels that you can use for your content
and most importantly doesn't feel like
work and doesn't feel like you're not
doing enough
because you have your regular show
coming out that's actually helping
people
i love that okay i'm to do i'm going to
do 50 reach outs today
and i'm going to call the ymca
i love it there you go yeah like the
speaking is is harder because
you know you have to do more outreach
and you not everybody's going to say yes
and just make sure you're filming it you
know that we see you on stage but ymc's
are great school assemblies are great um
at school yeah i mean now school might
be hard but i don't know if summer
school is still doing like assemblies
and stuff but um libraries awesome um
any community groups clubs meetups like
anything where you can basically be
on any kind of stage and then film it
like oh she's a speaker
you know so even if i just won a month
of those
um
at the very early stage of my career i
did it
there was a group called enterprise
toronto that's in my city that supports
entrepreneurs
and i would speak there
for like 50 bucks
for an hour and a half and there'd be 12
people in there or something you know
yeah um i did it more just to serve and
to help the community
i wish i had content like now i would do
it for free just to get content so that
i have something for my
my instagram and youtube channels um but
there's a lot of different community
like are you in a decent size city
yeah i'm in the phoenix metropolitan
area
um yeah i mean phoenix is huge so many
so many different groups so many
different clubs so many different
organizations um
that they would love to have a speaker
and just don't be attached to oh i need
to have a thousand people in the room
you know right time people show up
you're there to serve and film the
content so that you have something that
you could put up
um on your channels and i think it's
also great just to show the journey you
know just uh here's where i started
everybody i didn't start
once you're on stage and you know
oprah's introducing you and you know
you're doing your duet with garth brooks
or you know whatever whatever it is
that's happening uh
you get to show like the early starts
and the humble beginnings and
the early stage work that you did and
that was still
it was still just about helping people
more than about i need to have you know
a thousand people or ten thousand people
in the room yeah you and kyra in the
front row
of course we'll be singing along
cool well i know we don't have uh we're
actually a little bit over but let's
let's talk quickly about your book what
you've got coming up
healing through broken relationships
like maybe a just a quick overview or
some advice you've got so we can
let my audience know about it
um okay if i could tell everybody one
thing
about these books and i'm gonna i'm
actually just gonna put them all
together
it's that
wherever you put
your attention in your relationships
and how much you put in is what you're
going to get out
so my husband and i were married 12
years we had four kids didn't put a lot
of time and attention got divorced i was
married with our fifth
got remarried three years later and now
we put in so much time and effort into
this relationship
that
it it may not work out it may not you
never know what life's gonna bring but
because we put so much time and effort
our relationship is so sweet and i find
that in every relationship what you put
in is what you'll get out so wherever
you are in your relationships um
the brokenness is a gift
because it opens you up for healing in
other areas of your life and it shows
you
what you need to work on
i love it sprinkle little tidbits in
there it's great well everybody go check
out randa appreciate you book comes out
in september
september yep september go check it out
randa thank you for doing a hard thing
it was how hard was this was it was it
as scary as you thought
no you're amazing you're amazing i
appreciate you coming on i'm looking
forward to your content coming up and uh
good luck on your new coaching show
so we got michael in the house michael's
uh part of movement maker has been with
us uh
for the year and and it's back and uh as
part of that we do uh ig live to see how
we can help and go further so
what do you got man how can i help i
have a question um
i want to be an author speaker and coach
but as far like first i want to be an
author and i want to do uh
fiction and non-fiction and infuse my
message with that so what
what my question is what would be the
best way to
position myself to be an author
what's the first book
uh my first book i want to do a
non-fiction book
uh it's called bridging the gap uh it's
a book about uh bridging the gap between
able-bodied people and disabled people
and it's just telling my story
and uh having messages like that
and how far away from being done is the
book
oh um
a few months
being honest i just started and have you
worked through the process of like your
your cover and the layouts of the pages
or it's like a few months from a
manuscript being done
i know what the cover is going to be but
i just don't have i haven't worked out
the layout because
honestly i don't know how to do that i'm
just in the writing writing stage right
now
okay cool are you going to self-publish
it are you looking to
get a publisher or myself publish it
okay so the good news of that is
you know you're in control of your own
timeline
yeah and it makes sense honestly for
your first book to just get it out there
and build some momentum and you have
something people can go and check out
um
a couple things is so is your question
around just creating the book or
questions around marketing the book or
where where you suck
marketing
because i want to
let people know that i am an author and
i'm doing this and just a great buzz
around it so that
when it's done people know it it's
happening or has happened and i can
get it out to people
cool so you have two
there's a there's a there's a parallel
plan of action
okay okay
uh one is you're using other people's
audiences
so whenever you see some new author come
out or an office with a new book come
out they're they're going on other
people's shows
spreading the message
and letting people know and you're
hoping to tap into that person's
audience like anybody here watching
you're already tapping into my audience
they can learn about you and what it's
all about but when you're in book launch
mode you're thinking everybody who
you've done anybody who's in your
network anybody who've done an interview
with anybody who you've had on your on
your show
you're asking for help and support in
the book and on launch week
okay so whenever launch is out you're
you're you have a reason to go on people
shows and reconnect with people who you
like make a list of everybody who has
ever emailed you
who you've ever been on their show any
new connections people who follow you on
instagram
um
if it's not that big a number like for
instagram for example i'd be sending a
video dm to everybody who follows you
okay okay like how many people follow
you on instagram right now
uh
2500
perfect so 2500 video dms
you know it's like you're doing 90 a day
for a month and you get it out okay so
uh
it's it's a lot of personal
relationships and just asking and some
people will say
some people won't respond some people
will say no and some people say yes and
it's not um it's most of the time it's
not personal it's just timing and
everything else angela says i'll buy the
book so there you go here you go you
really got some so like angela you
should go on angela's show yeah when
you've already been on angela's show
right
yes i have and she's been online right
so round two should be like when you got
a book to actually talk about he was my
first guest angela was your first guest
she was yeah amazing i love it what a
first guest that's great it was awesome
so so phase one is is you're tapping
other people's audiences and
um
the way to ask uh who just messaged me
uh i'm thinking about lisa billy who i
just had on uh her book comes out on may
10th
so i just interviewed her where and and
the vineyards in the drop on may 8th
um
and the message was hey i'm launching my
new book
uh i mean we obviously know each other
so it's it's not like a random instagram
follower but she said
totally okay if you don't want to
promote it if you have space and time
and it's open i'd love to
try to get more awareness right and
that's basically the approach it's like
hey i've got this new book here's what
it's all about
hopefully it's a fit for your audience i
appreciate your friendship if there's
any space to come on and talk about it
to your audience and do an instagram
live or a zoom it i super appreciate it
and no pressure either way right and and
you do that for everybody who you've
connected with and so
ideally in launch week and and you know
even that whole month you are lining
people up and doing as many interviews
and shows as you can and
uh try to block off time from whatever
other responsibilities you have you know
that you're
that might get in the way so that you
can do five hours a day of interviews
with people right
um
that's a short-term strategy to get the
book out
you know and hopefully in the audience
you have people who then end up buying
so that's round one right people who you
know connected to and people who follow
you you're reaching out and dm and say
you've got this new book phase two is a
longer term approach which is making
content okay and
the idea then is you're not just tapping
in other people's audiences but you're
building your own audience in the
process
okay because you have more than just one
book in you
right you've got multiple books coming
out you've got everything else that you
want to do so building up your own
audience and that's where the content
comes in you're making you're doing your
shows i know you you do the show with
lady lexie you got a new show with nick
now you you're you're doing all this
content which is great and that starts
getting people into your world so that
they are potentially interested not just
in this book but in future books so that
if you have 2 500 followers now by the
time the next book comes out that's 25
000 followers or 10 000 followers or 100
000 followers or a million followers or
whatever it is people following you on
your journey
it's the content game is a much longer
term
approach
okay but it's worth it because you're
going to be
doing this for a while and you got a lot
of books inside you so it's usually that
combination like the immediate hit is
the shows that you can't go on right now
and then the ongoing long-term brain
play for all your future books is you're
constantly building your own your own
audience up as well okay
should i as i'm writing the book should
i do videos on
each chapter to like give me give people
an overview or advertise
for sure like tie it into your content
so and not just your
not just your own content but the other
content that you're doing so if you go
on somebody else's show
like
you you should be tying it in to this
episode right now
okay
so we can make it very meta so we're
doing we're talking you know
we're doing a coaching session here
which is great
what chapter
in your book
most relates to what we're talking about
right now it's probably the beginning
like just
you're starting your story and
um
getting
yourself comfortable
enough to
go forward with the journey
great so you bring it up like this so
hey evan i'm i'm writing my new book
it's called what's it called bridging
the gap
virginia gap so i know and so you
mentioned it before but now like where
we mention it the tagline is
starting a conversation with starting a
conversation to end the stigma
cool so that that's like the that that
you can get in i wouldn't bring that up
every time like it's called bridging the
gap yeah so i'm writing my new book it's
called bridging the gap and
you know in chapter one i'm talking
about just the comfort to share my own
story and get out of my comfort zone and
feel like my story has has meaning and
purpose and right now i'm struggling
with how do i get more marketing
on my book you know so you're trying to
tie in we're talking about it without
talking about it yeah yeah i get it yeah
so it's not a surprise that hey
michael's got this book coming up
so now you're orienting like me towards
book but anybody who's watching live or
on the replay
gets to
hear about the book
and so you're trying to bring up the
name so bridging the gap now remember
because you said it twice right you said
it the first time i forgot it the first
time and i remember the second time
right
um and so think about with your show
with lady or your show with nick
there's always something that you're
talking about on the show that's going
to relate to something that's in the
book
yeah okay
yeah so you try to bring that up it's
not a it's not um don't think of it as
like a promotion i mean it's a promotion
strategy i guess but it's more about
value to the conversation
because whenever whatever you're talking
about with your co-host
you could tell five different stories
you've got lots of stories that you
could share
so so choose to pull one from the book
so it allows you to talk about the book
and then
hopefully one of the hosts picks up on
that and then asks you oh so how's the
book coming along like where are we at
like oh i still got three months away
and i'm still working on my design and
my cover and i'm looking for somebody to
help me oh maybe that sparks like you
should talk to
this person
okay
you know or maybe someone in the
audience says oh how about connecting to
that person right
um i mean you should talk to terry for
sure terry does a lot of the the book
stuff um
even even in you asking the question
like it starts guiding
the host and the conversation towards
now talking about the book and it
doesn't have to be heavy-handed it's not
like you come in and said i need to talk
about my book and it's the only thing
we're talking about today right
you're not going to do that but but
making sure to try to bring it up
wherever you can
inside
content
but the stretch would be not just your
own content it'd be
other people's content too or your co
your co-hosting shows from the co-host
of content as well okay all right
i like that okay
and that starts now i mean you're you're
three months away from having a
manuscript done and then and then it's
editing and then it's
copy and cover design and upload into
amazon and getting approved and all the
all of the take people in on that
journey yeah and wait that long because
it
all that time will be lost and wasted
not necessarily wasted i mean it's it's
it's going into the writing but it's not
going into the marketing it's not going
to the storytelling and you could have
people
who knows maybe somebody watching this
becomes the next great connection for
you
um well i mean i introduced you to nick
yeah couple days ago it was that good
that was amazing by the way thank you
that like what what a great guy huh the
first few minutes we knew we wanted to
do a show
and that's great i don't even know how
we i mean you joined my live stream
while i was playing league of legends
and and i don't even know how
i got to
nick and you
but for whatever reason you being there
made me think of nick he's like these
guys should connect and and now you're
hosting your own show together it's
fantastic that was great yeah
so it's that it's like it's showing up
being on people's shows and then talking
about
what you're going through and what
you're excited about and what you're
struggling with
in terms of the book project and it'll
start to align people towards wanting to
help you
with the book project okay that's good
yeah that sounds good um
yeah that's that's all i really really
need help with me i'm gonna
keep going with the uh
with after writing i'm gonna on a
transcendent transition to
speaking and coaching but that's later
on
because i'm honestly the reason i'm
doing part of the reason i'm doing the
shows is because i'm not as good at the
speakers i want to be
and i'm trying to become a better
speaker
we're always in the cons i'm getting
better as a speaker too right
we're always in the constant journey of
improving and getting better which is
part of the fun i think doing shows is
great it helps a lot of speaking
is more
um like having almost have not quite a
set speech but it's not as interactive
you know like when you have a co-host
it's a different vibe than if you're
the guy on stage doing it so if the goal
is to be a speaker
you'll get better practice probably just
talking to the camera
because when you step on stage it's
michael solo you know there'll be
somebody introducing you michael
you know whatever and then you you get
on stage and start doing your thing but
it's it's mostly you
and so the best practice would be
direct to camera or even better is like
going and speaking at
ymcas or
lions club i mean i started the ymca but
libraries
like anything that
whether it's paid or not you have a live
audience of seven people to go and talk
to
not so much to pay so it's just about
the the doing right now
getting the message so you like what
where where do you live what city you're
in las vegas you're in vegas
i knew you were in vegas because we were
talking about meeting up when i when i
come and zan's there too i mean there's
so much
in vegas
and not just like strip but just even
just schools and libraries and ymcas and
lions clubs and whatever um
yeah they that
if that becomes a goal then
obviously the book is priority right now
but i'd be looking at how do you i mean
that can help sell the book too like you
go and speak and
part of that they may not pay you to
speak but they might buy your books yeah
you know a lot of that a lot of a lot of
authors end up selling their books from
speaking gigs
okay where you could be at the back
afterwards
taking questions and signing books like
it could be a book signing event where
you're speaking and then people who want
can buy your book and get a signed copy
because you're there okay
the reason i like uh empowering this
discussion so much is because it's i'm
the only host
so it's just me and they and the guests
i have so that's a lot more
you know
just me talking which helps me out helps
a lot
yeah and and when you end up speaking
you'll again it's you without
unless you're going to bring a guest on
with you on stage right you know it's
mostly going to be you it doesn't have
to be the skills that you practice and
work on a lot now but um
that'll be your
for anybody who wants to be a speaker
you should be out speaking
like once a month go out and speak and
what's usually great is if you have even
if you're
the bar is pretty low for most speakers
for for most of like the small events
like to speak at a library or a high
school or a community club or something
the bar is pretty low
and
a lot of the organizations are are just
craving for people to come in and share
their story and help
because a lot of people are really
struggling so
if you go in and do a good job
even a half decent job you know they'll
probably want you to come back
yeah i get that yeah yeah so it's once
you get the ball rolling a little bit
it's not that hard if the goal was to
speak every two weeks
you might get that
just from two different organizations
where you're coming in once a month and
talking to them
okay
that's good you know
um
you know for
for i've been thinking like there was um
toronto i live in toronto there's a
enterprise toronto which is a local
local government organization that helps
entrepreneurs get their business started
and they had these morning
seminars that they would run
and i would speak at and
this is early days of my speaking career
and i just wanted to i wanted to have
human contact it's not just
me on youtube you know i was like oh i
get to see somebody
shake hands and help them and yeah i
went in once and then then they wanted
me to come back i don't know every two
weeks every month
and and just do it again and do it again
until i just
couldn't commit to the schedule anymore
um
which i mean that's the speaking game
like you start off you do a whole bunch
you do it for free you you end up then
getting paid 100 bucks or 200 bucks or
whatever and you you work your way up to
bigger and bigger
opportunities
yeah okay
um
but yeah that could be a great place to
talk about the book promote the book
if you can fill it even better because
now you have content for your youtube
channel
and people see you as a speaker
okay
um i don't know how high like priority
level that is for you right now but
probably right below author honestly
well then what's stopping you from
reaching out to all the local libraries
and high schools and saying hey i'm a
speaker
i didn't know that they did like
speeches
at uh libraries honestly i mean i should
i should look into it more
i've checked out the uh ted talks but i
didn't see anything
um ted talks are good too ted talks a
lot more structured you know you have to
have it a certain amount of time and
still in vegas there's still going to be
a lot of ted talks that yeah that come
through um
yeah
libraries for sure libraries have tons
of stuff
high schools just
high schools you might have to just do
more outreach okay like libraries will
often have on their website
a list of activities a list of events
and lists of talks and
lists of stuff that's happening
high schools is more um obviously around
the school year so you're still good for
now but summer would wouldn't be as good
and they have assemblies
and people come in and speak at us like
the easiest one did you grow up in vegas
when i was york i moved to vegas about
20 years ago
okay did you go to high school in vegas
i graduated in in 97 so i've
been out of school
after uh since i could
since i've been here
okay i moved here no too so i mean any
any connections to
high schools
elementary schools
yeah okay friends any anybody like hey
they have kids i'd like to or you can
just email out
to the schools themselves like it's not
that high you just let them know you're
focused on bridging the gap
you tell them a quick pitch it's not
like the highest bar to come in and
speak at a high school assembly
um but great
great experience and dude you've got
such a moving story it's definitely
going to inspire some people in the room
um
any any organizations
where people who um
are recently disabled
i mean yeah i don't tell you how much
people struggle with that how to deal
with oh yeah adjusting so whatever i
don't know i'm not feeling with like
what's going on in vegas with community
organizations but there are definitely
are
yeah to come in and reach out and the
unfortunate thing is is there's people
becoming disabled every day right and
they're struggling with it every day so
you could be in there every week
speaking to a new
group of people
and sharing your story and helping them
um
i mean that's a huge huge need
yeah so getting plugged into that
again you could be there every week or
every month it becomes whatever
whatever frequency you end up wanting to
do it at
um
yeah like i would start if that's your
number two priority right behind
writing
yeah
yeah then yeah and they go very well
together
oh yeah i'm sure speaker and author are
very complimentary things like honestly
speaking will make you a better author
because when you're speaking
like writing a book a nonfiction book is
basically
they're both coaching like you want
people to learn something and then
make an improvement or mindset shift in
their life that they take home and
change something in their life right
like from your story i'm going to be
inspired to then make a change in my
life
otherwise
what's the point of writing a nonfiction
book
um so you're coaching without any
feedback or at least when you're
speaking you get feedback
afterwards people come up and say hey
how about this like the questions that
people ask you afterwards might become
new chapters in your book and make your
book even better
that's a good idea
because you're seeing what resonates
i've written fiction before but i've
never written this a non-fiction so i'm
just i'm struggling with
the structure right now
what the order of things should be
well that's where speaking then can be
fantastic
because your speech has a structure to
it
yeah so the speech should be a
paired down version of the book
like i could do a speech on built to
serve
but then if they want more details they
can go buy the book but the built to
serve book is based off of me doing a
lot of mostly coaching and some speaking
around the concepts there but then you
know what works if you go on stage and
you tell the first story that's in your
book
maybe that lens maybe it doesn't land
you know you don't know until you
actually start you i mean i think all my
stories are great but you don't know
until
until you actually start talking to
people and testing it out
but when you go off and give a speech
and you tell a couple stories
and then afterwards the best part is
afterwards people come up to you and say
hey michael wow that was so inspiring
how did x and they ask you questions
whatever story
they're asking the most questions around
or whatever follow-up they're asking
after listening to your speech that's
all great content for what you know
works well that then should be in the
book okay
it's a good idea
so they work super well together
even as you're playing through your
material
which story should you tell you can you
can test it from a stage
okay even the stage isn't a thousand
people but the stage is whoever's you
know is in the room and yeah
and then the feedback afterwards will it
will definitely make you a better writer
okay for sure
um my book built to serve kane because i
was on a speaking tour
yeah i i i heard that yeah
people kept asking the same question i
wasn't on tour i wasn't even on tour
talking about built to serve i was
talking about something else
and people kept asking me the same
questions in every city which led to i
should just write a book on this which
then became built to serve
yeah
i hadn't thought of that yeah it's a
good idea so it's great to get the
feedback so
yeah i mean i would just start making a
list today of
you're in vegas so it's not even noon
yet
no
so so you got time make a list of of
high schools libraries
community organizations
especially ones related to disability
somehow new newly disabled people um
and any other community groups in vegas
that might be a fit for what you're
doing okay build out a list of a couple
hundred places get their email addresses
and just start emailing people and say i
want to come i'll come and speak
for free to your audience
here's my here's my topic
you'll get you'll get like if you only
do 10 you may not get any right yeah but
if you make a list of 100 you'll get
you'll get at least five
i do 400 and get 10 10 yeses i'm good
yeah yeah but that's it so like most
people they won't do enough
of the outreach
they'll they'll make a list of four and
email all four and they don't hear a
response and so then oh i guess that
strategy didn't work yeah
but if you can actually make a list of
400 you will get at least 10. yeah and
then you're off and speaking okay great
thank you
yeah
cool well it's exciting man yeah yeah me
too yeah i've been looking forward to
this yeah
yeah so you got you got a couple months
out so you know strategies recap we've
got
reaching out to all of the shows that
you've been on and all the co-hosts that
you've had and all the guests you've had
and asking for support
video dming everybody who follows you on
instagram and telling them that you've
got your new book out you'd love to
support no expectations just let them
know what you've done
you know 90 people a day for a month
yeah get those videos going eight
seconds at a time the hand-to-hand
combat
continue to make your own content and
pouring in
stories from the book and lessons as
much as possible so it's not a surprise
for people to hear that you're an author
that everybody knows you're working
through this book and then for speaking
it's starting to reach out to ymcas and
libraries and
high schools
make a list of a couple hundred and
reach out and say you've got a story to
share about bridging the gap
and start getting some speaking gigs
great thank you man i appreciate it you
got it if you want to see me coach
another entrepreneur check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there just don't accept the way
things are done as the way that it has
to be done so just because they stop
selling books it doesn't mean that they
can't sell your book you don't pitch
them as help they sell my book
you don't pitch them we're not even
selling a book